[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part 3 geodesics
in the previous videos we have defined
the concepts of world lines
motion as proper time goes by and
velocity
which indicates the direction in which
an object moves through space and time
we would now like to describe the
evolution of this velocity
as proper time passes in order to
predict the shape of the trajectory
in our universe objects naturally move
in straight lines
when no force is applied world lines
tend to be straight
through the dimensions of space and time
this comes from the symmetry of such
trajectory
an object has no reason to turn one way
or the other
this simple consideration gives us a
method to predict the trajectory of a
body
as soon as we know its velocity at a
given instant we can just transport the
arrow along
itself to gradually predict the movement
of the object
this type of trajectory which is formed
by transporting velocity along itself
is called a geodesic
[Music]
in the universe all objects tend to
follow geodesics
on a geodesic the vector does not turn
we can thus write that its derivative
with respect to proper time
is zero along the trajectory
the velocity vector of the apple does
not vary
this equation simply says that the
natural movement of bodies
is non-accelerating and therefore that
when they experience no
force objects tend to move straight
ahead
but we saw previously that the velocity
vector can be written as the sum of its
components
multiplied by the basis vectors
[Music]
using this expression and knowing that
the derivative of a product
is the sum of each term multiplied by
the derivative of the other term
we obtain a relation between on one side
the change in the components of the
velocity
and on the other side the change in the
basis vectors themselves
the basis vectors can indeed vary
throughout the trajectory
because the grid that we choose as our
coordinate system can very well be
irregular
although the vector remains the same as
a geometric object
its components on the grid can vary as
the apple moves
when we think about it the evolution of
a basis vector along the world line
can be decomposed as the sum of its
evolution
along each of the two coordinates
multiplied by the speed of the apple
because the faster the apple moves
the faster the basis vector will vary
[Music]
for each coordinate this gives us a new
quantity
which indicates how the basis vector
varies along the coordinate
this variation is expressed as a vector
that is the derivative of the basis
vector with respect to the coordinate in
question
this vector is very interesting because
it no longer depends on the trajectory
but only on the structure of the grid
itself
this vector can be expressed through its
components
denoted by the capital letter gamma
in our two-dimensional case these
components
exist in eight different versions two
components
for four different vectors these numbers
are called christopher symbols the
christopher symbols are essential
quantities for general relativity
because they encode how the grid changes
along each
direction they contain crucial
information
on how our coordinates behave
[Music]
rewriting the previous equation using
christopher symbols
we finally get to the geodesic equation
this very important equation allows us
to calculate for
each component of the velocity its rate
of change
as proper time passes
the geodesic equation thus allows us to
predict the whole trajectory of an
object
as long as we know its velocity at a
given moment
and the value of each christopher symbol
all throughout the grid
to illustrate all these ideas let's
imagine not a space-time
but simply the surface of the earth
we decide to use a latitude longitude
coordinate system
which at first glance seems to be a very
good fit for the geometry
now imagine that an airplane is moving
in a straight line
when an object moves straight ahead
without ever turning
its trajectory forms what is called a
geodesic
in our situation the geodesic is a great
circle around the planet
on this geodesic trajectory the airplane
is always moving straight ahead
its velocity vector does not change
orientation
but when we plot the coordinates the
trajectory seems
curved the airplane seems to change
orientation along the grid
in reality its trajectory is perfectly
straight
the problem does not come from the
airplane but from our grid
it's our coordinates that are curved
their axes do not correspond
to straight lines on a sphere compared
to real straight lines
geodesics they turn
starting from a basis vector and
transporting it along the grid
we can measure how much this vector
changes by another vector
it's the components of this vector that
are called christophel symbols
the christopher symbols measure the
extent to which our coordinates deviate
from straight lines
along the grid
[Music]
you